is there advice you can give
to uh young people today that look at
your story that's successful in many
dimensions
um advice you can give to them about how
to be successful in their career
successful in life in whatever path they
choose
yes i would say listen to advice
and see it for what it is a mirror
of that person and then map and know
that your future
is going to be in a zeroth principle
land and so
what you're hearing today is a
representation of what may have been the
right principles to build upon
previously
but they're likely depreciating very
fast
and so i am a strong proponent
that people ask for advice
but they don't take advice
so how do you take advice properly
it's in the careful examination of the
advice it's it's actually
you the person makes a statement about a
given thing somebody should follow
the value is not doing that the value is
understanding the assumption stack they
built
the assumption and knowledge stack they
built around that that body of knowledge
that's the value it's not doing what
they say considering the advice
but digging deeper to understand the
assumption stack like the full person
it's almost i mean this is deep empathy
essentially
to understand the journey of the person
that arrives at the advice
and the advice is just the tip of the
iceberg that's right that ultimately is
not the thing that gives you that's
right
it could it could be the right thing to
do it could be the completely wrong
thing to do depending on the assumption
stack
so you need to investigate the the whole
thing is there
some are there been people in your
startup in your business journey
that have served that role of advice
giver
has been helpful or did do you feel like
your journey
felt like a lonely path
or was it one that was of course we're
all
we all are born and die alone uh but
uh do you fundamentally remember the
as one where you leaned on people at a
particular moment of time that changed
everything
yeah the most significant moments of my
memory
for example like on kilimanjaro when ike
some person i'd never met in tanzania
was able to in that moment apparently
see my soul
when i was in this death match with
reality yes
and he gave me the instructions look up
step
and so
there's magical people in my life
that have done things like that and
i suspect they probably don't know i i
probably should be better at identifying
those things and
but yeah hopefully the
i suppose like the wisdom i would aspire
to
is to have the awareness and the empathy
to be that for other people and
not a a retail
advertiser of advice of tricks and
for life but uh deeply meaningful
and empathetic with a one-on-one context
with people
that it really could make a difference
yeah i actually kind of experienced i
think about that sometimes
you know you have like a 18 year old kid
come up to you
it's not always obvious it's not always
easy
to really listen to them like not
not the facts but like see who that
person is
i think people say that about being a
parent is
you know you want to consider that
you don't want to be the authority
figure in a sense that you really want
to consider that there's a special
unique human being there with a unique
brain
that may be um brilliant in ways that
you are not understanding
that you'll never be and really try to
hear that
so when giving advice there's something
to that so both sides should be
deeply empathetic about the assumption
stack
i love that the terminology
you